un optimista regreso más de 840.000
estudiantes volvieron a las escuelas
públicas en panamá luego de una huelga
de docentes que se prolongó durante casi
un mes bueno me siento contenta porque
los niños regresaron era verdad que yo
tenían que regresar a su jaula aprender
más y bueno finalmente se logró lo que
estaban buscando los maestros como los
padres de familia que estaban peleando
en la calle sus derechos cuadernos
listos y útiles en la mesa se pueden ver
en más de 3000 aulas que habían
permanecido vacías mientras los maestros
demandaban al gobierno modificaciones en
el sistema educativo además de una
rebaja en la canasta básica en los
medicamentos y en el combustible los
docentes dejaron las calles y se
sentaron a negociar con el gobierno tras
la firma de un documento pactado entre
ambas partes volvieron a sus labores el
texto contempla 21 acuerdos de los
puntos planteados por los educadores
uno de sus principales el gobierno
asignará un 55 por ciento del pib en
2022 para la educación y un 6% en 2024
es decir cerca de 1200 millones de
dólares estamos conscientes de que esos
niños también son hijos de docentes y
hoy por hoy les doy gracias a dios que
no se llevó más tiempo del que se llevó
para lograrlo todo lo que se logró
en el último mes las calles panameñas se
llenaron de las protestas más intensas
en décadas el sector educativo fue uno
de sus principales promotores al que se
sumaron sindicatos gremios
organizaciones indígenas y la sociedad
civil las manifestaciones derivaron en
que el gobierno de laurentino cortizo
congelará el precio del combustible y de
algunos productos de la canasta básica
además de un plan de austeridad que
reduce en 10% la planilla estatal y los
gastos de los ministros